dion is in bakersfield california
starting this hour off hi dion how are
you
how you doing dave finally got the
chance to talk to you and i'm sorry
i'm trying to this is my first time
talking i don't know how to do all this
but
i'm trying i've been reaching out trying
to reach out to your company for
years now this is my first time well i'm
glad you got through how can we help you
today
um i just purchased my first home
and two years ago i'm trying to figure
out a way
as a blind person how to pay off my
mortgage faster than
30 years okay okay dion
did you say a blind person excuse me i'm
sorry did you say a blind
person yes sir okay so what do you do
for a living
i receive social security okay all right
and how expensive a home did you buy in
bakersfield california
uh it's actually right next door to in
lancaster
but it's uh we paid 240 000.
you said we are you married yeah yes sir
okay
what does she do for a living she's a um
caregiver she takes care of elderly okay
so what's your household income then
uh i received social security 900 a
month she receives about
2 600 a month
and we also have a side gig we
uh after we moved into our house she was
taking care of one of the
people she was taken care of and um
their
spouse passed away and we took them in
and we've been doing it so we take care
of um
elderly in our home as well and what
does that pay
uh we receive about we have two patients
right now we
receive about 2200 dollars straight
across money
okay okay so that's about 500 a month
yeah that makes
that makes that makes us a little bit i
didn't think you were paying a
mortgage on a 200 something thousand
dollar house with 3 600 bucks so this is
helpful
good okay good so you did that because
you had this mortgage and you had to do
something right
yes sir good well no well actually my
dad was living with us before he passed
away too so that was another reason why
we were able to
get the house and my wife was receiving
he had more patience at the time before
the coronavirus gotcha so what's your
question for today then
i'm trying to find out how to pay off my
home faster i've been hearing stuff i've
compared all faster than 30 years i've
been following you since i've been since
i was 16 i'm 52 now
so before we go there uh dion do you
have any other consumer debt
excluding your mortgage no we don't have
any credit card debt
we pay all credit cards in full every
month um
we own both of our cars so no we don't
have any debt at all
so you do have debt you just paid off
every month
oh well i i follow stupid people and
tell me about credit
he said he has credit cards and he pays
it off every month oh okay but you know
you don't have a balance on them so yeah
yeah so you're going to get debit cards
to replace those but then
as far as paying off the house early you
just we're going to put you on a budget
make sure you have your emergency fund
in place
and start saving 15 of your income
towards
retirement past that every dollar you
can find
up to baby step six is gonna go towards
the house unless i miss something that's
where he is yeah no he didn't miss
nothing at all dave i mean i
definitely want to say uh get rid of the
credit cards though
i mean because that's going to put you
back into debt um eventually
i i i'm just going to say that so first
time there's a hiccup you're going to
end up
and you're going to look over on those
things there's going to be a balance
he's right about that but
um i think the big thing here is you
guys have done a great job of scrap
being scrappy
you're hustling you're grinding you're
adding you know adding people into your
home that you're taking care of she's
working
you know you guys are doing everything
you can do to make sure that you make
the payments on this house
and you've always figured out a way you
know and so
that's good news right and i would just
use that scrappiness and not use it as a
way to
uh save your bacon every time but
instead be a way that you
that you're actually prospering and that
comes from working the baby steps and
doing that with a budget
and uh you know baby step one's debt
free except the home you've done that
two is an emergency fund of three to six
months or two is debt snowball
three is emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses
and you move straight up through that
process